so nice to have you here and we've been
talking about this for years but I I
love Silicon Valley I just love the show
I'm kind of heartbroken that it's
winding up but I'm really loving this
season it's great it's really good yeah
you we saw each other backstage and you
mentioned that your son watches the show
yeah I lied yeah yeah you don't have a
son and we don't own a television yeah
you're more of a wireless radio no yeah
my son my son is really into tech and he
just turned 14 and he absolutely loves
the show so we watch it together
as like that's the thing we do together
because we don't speak and but he's
absolutely a little it's like you're his
hero that you're a character he just
loves your character well I love I've
now I'm gonna sit be creepy to your son
I love you back I don't know how I
didn't like that
[Applause]
it was good that's all the time we have
goodbye Zack that's all the time we have
in this friendship you know you getting
your so creepy let's our God keep
digging the hole deeper sorry you know I
want to mention this because there's so
many cool things that you get to do you
know when you when you have a hit TV
show and you're part of this great cast
you do a lot of nice things too
I'm told that you visited it's just like
a juvenile like a juvenile prison right
I want their friend of mine works with
this organization called
inside-out writers which helps do
writing workshops for incarcerated youth
and I went to one of their workshops and
these are these young people do they
know Silicon Valley do they know who you
are
I don't think so yeah but it was
interesting going in I was like I don't
really have a sense of what the sort of
frame of references in terms of what
television is popular among the kids in
there but I went in and the guy who I
was with said he had me stand up in
front of all of these guys I was like
what do you think this guy does for a
living
which was such a loaded but so rare to
be in a room of people with where they
say like what's this guy's basic vibe
especially like very tough teenagers
scary yeah so I thought is it gonna be
like Internet a mortuary or definitely
not someone who's getting paid
apprenticeship homes just there for the
perfect deejay at like a
I just work here for the smell but no
what they said was and I was very
delighted they weren't multiple kids
said he's your skateboarder they think
you're a skateboarder because I was
wearing a button-down shirt and canvas
shoes so I think they were like that's a
skateboarder little do they know I have
never stepped on a skateboard in my life
because I feel precarious and
off-balance enough just in daily you and
I have you and I have a similar build
right which is our center of gravity is
up here in the Adam's apple and so I
like when anything that involves like
incredible balance no I would just go
over like a like a bad tree yes like a
bad tree that had gone rotten the limbs
the only thing I've ever done that is
close to skateboarding and it's really
not that close is and when I lived in
New York I bought a folding bike this is
like little bike that is low to the
ground and you fold it up to take it
into the subway so that you can go
anywhere but I it was too heavy for me
to carry into the subway so you couldn't
lift the folding bike I could lift it
but it was a real production and I just
like lugging it down the steps it was
just too much so I would ride it along
the West Side Highway but I was so
scared of getting hit by cars that I
just covered myself in reflectors and
lights and I had like I had a helmet
with lights on it and a vest and lights
on my on like a lot of lights and I was
driving driving I was riding down the
West Side Highway and all these women
kept looking at me and I was like yes I
got the Battery Park and then I saw
myself in one of these like reflected
glass buildings and I just looked
horrible
I just was like tall a bad tree on a
small bike covered in Christmas yeah you
got a look and you saw it maybe they
were looking at me more in wonder and
horror you know yes I mistook their
disgust and bewilderment for a track